hi guys it's me quinn and as always if
you appreciate my content consider
hitting the like button it's the only
way the youtube algorithm really notices
me
six singles remembrance verse past
series has become one of my top science
fiction series since i read it last year
keep in mind this video will have some
spoilers for the series
there are many haunting philosophical
quandaries brought up by the three body
problem series
but there is one that stuck with me more
than the others
one of the themes that weaves its way
throughout all of six and those books
revolves around whether or not we can
actually trust that our understanding of
the universe actually reflects its true
nature
as far as we can tell the universe is
about 14 billion years old
we calculate this by finding the oldest
stars and by measuring the rate of
expansion of the universe
by observing the current state of the
universe we can calculate backwards
towards the big bang
according to our best estimates there
are around 2 trillion galaxies in the
universe
200 billion trillion stars
and over 700 quintillion planets the
universe is estimated to be 28 billion
parsecs across
it would take light the fastest moving
thing in the universe 93 billion years
to go from one side to the other
hearing these numbers you might assume
that we understand a lot about the
universe
but in actuality all of these estimates
are barely more than educated guesses
the two things that seem clearest are
that the universe is incredibly old and
incredibly big it would be extremely
arrogant of us to think that from our
vantage point here on a tiny blue ball
orbiting a medium-sized star in a nine
planet solar system somewhere in a
lonely dark corner of the cosmos we
could actually grasp a full
understanding of the intricate
mechanisms that form the universe
we can only approximate
scientists accept that much of our
knowledge of the cosmos is subject to
change as we learn more about its nature
as research unveils never before
realized secrets of the universe and as
technologies make it easier for us to
observe our surroundings our
understanding of the cosmos evolves
the suggestion made in the three-body
problem series is however more
devastating than the idea of science
gradually being updated based on
advances in knowledge and technology
what if we are not merely wrong about a
few things
what if our entire understanding of what
the universe is and how it works is
wrong
the universe does in fact seem ancient
if it is at least 14 billion years old
as our science suggests
then probability would suggest that
there should have been countless
civilizations to exist before mankind
as i discussed in my last three-body
problem video the drake equation
suggests that the universe should be
full of other life
and if this is true then what potential
effect has said life had on the universe
considering the immense effect that the
existence of life has had upon the earth
in the third book in the series death
sinned the character yang yandong
witnesses a simulation depicting earth
throughout time with the variable of
life removed
in the modern era earth was a twin of
mars
humans often underestimated the effect
that life has had on the environment of
earth when yangdong considers this
concept and applies it to the universe
which she at this point in the story
understood was full of alien beings her
mind is brought to a new chilling
concept
if what we see when we look into the
cosmos is the universe exploding with
life
then what would it look like without
life
she tried to stop thinking
to turn her mind into empty darkness
but a new question stubbornly refused to
leave her alone
is nature really natural
nature as we see it may not be in fact
natural at all
the three body problem provides two
analogies and an attempt to explain this
concept
one far darker than the other
there is the shooter hypothesis on the
farmer hypothesis
we will start with the shooter
hypothesis
in the shooter hypothesis a good
marksman shoots at a target creating a
hole every 10 centimeters
now suppose the surface of the target is
inhabited by intelligent two-dimensional
creatures
their scientists after observing the
universe discover a great law
there exist a hole in the universe every
10 centimeters they have mistaken the
result of the marksman's momentary whim
for an unalterable law of the universe
we are observing the universe from a
particular place and time a blip on the
cosmic scale
just because the universe appears to us
in a certain way now does not mean that
it has always been this way or that it
will always be we are in this analogy
the two-dimensional beings only able to
measure the state of the universe as it
exists from our perspective
the universe may be operating based on
intricate schematics beyond our ability
to comprehend
to further drive home this point is the
farmer hypothesis
the far darker of the two analogies
every morning on a turkey farm the
farmer comes to feed the turkeys
a scientist turkey having observed this
pattern to hold without change for
almost a year
makes the following discovery
every morning at 11 food arrives
on the morning of thanksgiving the
scientist announces this law to the
other turkeys but that morning at 11 the
food doesn't arrive instead the farmer
comes and kills the entire flock
what is the universe
what is its nature to think that we can
know beyond a shadow of a doubt is to be
as arrogant as the scientist turkey
we must consider that the universe may
have a deadly and eldritch function
one that if we could fully comprehend
might cause us to cry out in existential
agony
this hypothesis can also be viewed as
placing an emphasis on the potential
life that formed in the darkness of the
universe before we did
a high enough level civilization would
have almost god-like potential compared
to us in this metaphor they would be the
farmer and we the turkeys our place in
the universe could be a comfortable
illusion
for all we know we could already be in
the belly of the beast
this idea manifest itself in the series
in two clear ways
the alien beings known as the
tricelerins creation of sofons which
invisibly stifled the progress of human
development by rendering physics
unreliable from within our region of
space
and the existence of eons of
interactions and wars between the higher
dimensional beings that once inhabited
the higher dimensional universe before
it was gradually degraded by life we
discussed the latter in my video the
mystery of the fourth dimension the
trisolarene sophons are the most direct
example
the sophons operate it based on quantum
mechanical principles the word quantum
refers to the minimum unit of any
physical entity involved in interaction
so sophons were in fact very small
though they could unfold into higher
dimensions
sophons were essentially supercomputers
etched onto a proton
because of the principles of quantum
entanglement sophons on earth provided a
stream of instantaneous information
about earth to the tricelerin home world
in real time they watched and studied
the human race
the sofon supercomputer could impede the
progress of scientific development
wherever necessary and humankind was
incapable of stopping it they had
already been crippled
our understanding of the universe would
ultimately hit a standstill
the tricelerians would not allow any
development that could prevent their
invasion and habitation of the earth
in the first book in the series we
learned that scientists in different
fields throughout the world had been
committing suicide yandong included
this turned out to be the reason why
upon discovering that their entire lives
spent studying their particular feelings
of science had been rendered useless
they could not cope
humankind does eventually begin to
develop ways to thwart the tricelerins
the tricelerins do not have access to
the thoughts hidden away within the
human mind and the aliens unlike human
beings do not fully grasp the concept of
deception
because of this humanity invents the
wall face of project which we will go
into more detail about in another video
the struggle between humanity and the
tricelerians continues for centuries
both sides suffer greatly in the end
humanity would eventually learn that
there were others far more powerful and
deadlier than the trisolarens
our interaction with the inhabitants of
the trisolera
had itself been a mere blip on the
cosmic timeline
thank you guys so much for watching make
sure you like and subscribe for more
science fiction videos